I'd be corny about it I'd be like really
like exploring myself on that [__] hey
man there's a lot of people that they
like you have to set intentions before
you go into a trip and [__] like that
yeah I don't know about if I'm doing
that but like I'll see I like to [__] I
like to [__] get a good cry off on some
acid sometimes oh [__] you feel me like
I tried it really like I did some after
one time we were camping and then like
we saw a bear going to the store and
then my girl was like you know you were
like meant to see that bear
and I was like damn don't say that to me
right now no crying off the acid but I
just feel good to cry
everything in my life had led me to see
that bear
oh you can